[Music]
you've waited for your turn to the fire
burn and all that's to say is Wait fores
f r [Music] the Michael lanio we double
overtime the golden knights have
eliminated the Oilers to advance
to the Western Conference Final gred
hoing wins it in overtime for Vegas
congratulations to the Vegas golden knights
on their way to the Stanley Cup Final for the
second time Aiden Hill takes away a sure
goal martinz score a Devotion to Destiny
Misfits to [Applause] Champions the Vegas
Golden Knights win the Stanley Cup in 2020
3 let's go let's
[Music]
go the Vegas Golden Nights everybody a big
hand for the majority owner Mr Bill Foley
the Knight never gives up never gives in always
advances never Retreats and that's what our team
is going to be that's what George MC is going to
deliver on the ice and wins the Stanley Cup within
how many years well I did say seven years but it
should be six years now six years the Vegas golden
knights take the ice for the first time in their
history he had no idea what was going to happen
the first year NE shot the to score first goal in
Golden Nights history would they be entertaining
would they be fun to follow or would they lose
in blowouts every game that was not going to
be in the cards here we go boys and away we
go what was in the cards was a debut season
unlike anything the league had ever seen thanks
to a group of players in a unique situation they
shared the common Bond of having been cast off
by their previous team with a unique Nick name
it was James Neil at the time that it came up one
day he's just just a bunch of Misfits like no one
wanted us remarkably in year one the golden
Misfits somehow made their way to the Stanley
Cup Final and the score it's Riley Smith even
winning game one game one to the Vegas golden
knights but that was as far as they would get
losing to Washington in five games what a save
the save of this series incredible stop
by Braden Hy you know I think definitely
got a little overwhelmed in the finals for
sure gozi along the rank Circle a shot he
scores the fact that we collaps there
a little bit and lost Force trade oenin
score that's what disappointing that we
did not per for at the standard we had all
year this team is the result of losing the Stanley
Cup in the spring of 2018 Kelly McMan and George
MC looked at what they had and said this is good
but it's not good enough Kelly McMan said I need
a leader markstone well I ended up in Vegas
obviously through trade you know I love my
time playing for Ottawa I think it's no secret
that if I wasn't going to play my whole career
in Ottawa this is where I wanted to go when
I was asked and told that I was going to be
the first captain of this organization it you
know brings tears to your eyes means the world
to me to be the captain uh not only for this
organization the players but for the city of
Las Vegas Kelly McMan said I need a two-way
defenseman signed Alex petrangelo I told my
wife and she will agree that I said I'm not
going to move unless I think I have a chance
to win a cup the final piece of the puzzle
he said I need a franchise Center swung a
huge deal to get Jack eel you know that was the
first team on my wish list you know everyone's
so friendly and the organization goes so out
of their way to make you and and your family
feel comfortable here despite the additions the
2021 22 season wasn't what the knights expected
and for the first time in franchise history Vegas
actually missed the playoffs for all the success
they've had through the first four years Stanley
Cup Final appearance in year one three trips to
the final four no playoffs for the golden knights
this season which ultimately led to another big
change a new voice behind the bench the longtime
coach of the Boston Bruins Bruce Cassidy you know
I want to start by first thanking Bill Foley
Kelly George for putting their trust in me I
I think it's a privilege and an honor to be a
head coach in the National Hockey League and
and and so I'm very grateful for the opportunity
here in Vegas while Bill Foley came out and said
in year six he was going to win the Stanley Cup I
think at the end of the day the expectation was to
win the cup they' been there once they'd been to
the Conference Finals twice and I was perfectly
fine with that it's what I wanted I wanted to
win the cup and I wanted to go to a team with
matching values in that regard yeah he's brought
a different vibe I think he's very detailed in his
work brings a lot of raw emotion to the dressing
room we're going to play the game we're going to
manage the park we're going to be honor here
it's not easy when a new coach comes in but I
think he really did a good job of getting us all
to adapt quickly we got Nick we got your line we
got Marty P we got LT welcome to the home opener
fun and enthusiasm replacing the disappointment
of that injury Riddle campaign from a year ago
renewed confidence is back in the dress room
of the Vegas Golden Nights right from the start
the players bought in to Cassidy's plan winning
13 of their first 15 games walking in the SC at
1.9 in a row closes in then he shoots he scores
including one for the record books Phil kessle
has broken the NHL Iron Man record 990 consecutive
games even more impressive they were doing it with
a rookie goal tender what a f fabulous stop from
Logan Thompson tommer was definitely a backbone of
our group from the start Logan was playing awesome
for us he was relishing the opportunity to FBR
starting goer from the Vegas Golden Nights Logan
Thompson Logan Thompson certainly deserved to be
an All-Star he played fin H off the start of the
year but Midway through the season with Vegas
sitting on top of the Pacific Division the injury
bug began to wreak havoc on the golden knights
and good roll was stopped looked like Stevenson
Bing a piece of that Thompson shaking up that's
not good he can't get up that's not a good sign
for the golden knights as Logan Thompson still
down Logan was starting there and then he kind
of went down with an injury on near in Minnesota
so Aiden Hill coming on in relief at the start
of the year I didn't know if it was going to be
me or Logan Thompson starting there hop in there
got on a little run played some games I thought
I was playing good hockey like Thompson Aiden
Hill would get hurt too sideline for the last
month of the regular season and he wasn't the
only one out for an extended period of time yeah
I thought everything was going pretty smooth you
know obviously had the surgery last summer it was
January 12th against Florida went to make a play
and uh shooting pain went through my back again
quick update so Mar Stone played four shifts in
the first period really didn't play any in
the second half of the period no word just
yet on the status of the golden knights Captain
talked to a few different doctors and made the
decision to get the surgery that I decided
to get after the remarkable start Vegas had
struggled a bit playing 500 hockey for close to
40 games until the depth of their team began to
show AER scor PA coner rips at home a score the
go helped Along by the late season editions of
Ivan barbashev Teddy bler and Jonathan Quick
down the stretch Vegas won 22 of its last 31
games and the golden KN sweep the road trip
with a 4 or3 win in Ed 10 and finish with the
franchise best 111 points the golden knights are
Pacific Division Champions and the one seed in
the Western Conference and a chance to once again
play for the Stanley [Music] [Applause] [Music]
Cup
as the top seed in the Western Conference
the knights came into their first round
playoff series against the Winnipeg Jets
as heavy favorites especially with the
return of their Captain Mark Stone who had
missed the last 39 games of the regular
[Applause]
season they hadn't played in forever so was
very nervous I hadn't really taken a ton of
contact I think the team was nervous he's a guy
we were looking to probably too much in game one
he comes back so our guys were probably like oh
we got our captain back everything's going to be
easy from the left Circle a shot comes out in
front and Kyle Conor scores for the Jets one-
nothing win haveit in the opening minute and 24
seconds of period two the first game was tough
for sty for obvious reasons he' missed so much
time in Jack eel's first games he had a lot of
newness I dropped a big I mean I was terrible
in that game and our team didn't play good his
off stick at the Winnipeg line Jets sing shoots he
scores J catches the night's changing two nothing
win a pick in the opening minutes of the second
period it was almost like we were so amped up
and excited we just forgot how to play we didn't
play well we acknowledge that why didn't we play
well we mismanaged pucks I think guys were just a
little bit nervous not playing winning hockey kind
of laid an egg stop rebound comes in front no room
to shoot at first now they score Blake wheeler got
the backhander through and the Jets take a three
to one leads pegas a sweep I remember after the
game Chandler Stevenson grabbed me and he was like
it's not really what it's like it's a seven game
series that means nothing final score Winnipeg
Jets five Vegas golden knights [Applause] one
that's the playoffs right you regroup and you get
ready for the next one the Jets take a 1 series
lead do your job do it well here tonight and we'll
be just fine really good aey club it's your turn
to step in and get the job done make sure we're
there to do it all right it's okay to have a bad
game we corrected that going into game two the
second period was probably our turning point we
got some goals we found some confidence I think
that allowed us to settle in a bit Carlson and
now kle Carlson he scores that second period
and into the third we really started to find
our groove and start to dominate point onetime
petranto they score the knights Take the Lead
two to one Vegas across the line on the right wing
out to the left Stevenson for stone he scores it's
pretty crazy Stony took all that time off and came
back and looked like he didn't miss a beat that's
when he really felt like a okay I'm I'm back to
where I want to be game two he certainly found
it and he's that type of guy that the plays he
makes on the ice can lift everybody Carlson for
stone in front he scores Mark stone is back when
you score you see how happy everybody is you see
your teammates happy for you I meant a lot when
you have that emotion from your captain and your
best player that's going to carry down the group
just cuz of how much joy he brings in the moment
to to the plays he makes the goal he scores it
just gave me confidence and comfortability that
I was back to be able to do that and finally
feel part of the group again meant the world
to [Applause] me respond that took the whole
team who had to step on the gas and had lead this
obviously has to go to the guy who never skipped
the [Applause] beat boys took it over there let's
go I think that just says so much
about him as a player and his
character let go Baby with the series tied at
one game each Vegas headed north to Winnipeg
and through two periods of game three it looked
as if the knights had found their regular season
form racing to a 4 to1 lead but the Jets had other
ideas shoots and score as they mounted a furious
third period comeback we just got a little bit
tight I me we got a little complacent especially
in Winnipeg we know that building gets pretty
loud when they get a little bit of momentum
and we just didn't handle the momentum swing
that great give them credit they fought back
and you know they scored some timely goals in
that period up the wall kept in a Pon shot tip
save rebound they score 21 seconds to go the Jets
tie it I think I think after the regulation ended
we were able to come in the room and regroup a
bit there will be an overtime here in Winnipeg
this afternoon that's another situation that I
think it kept us honest a little bit the story
of Depp was prominent for the golden knights
they got contributions up and down the lineup
in that series Michael amadio less than two years
earlier had been placed on waivers by the Toronto
Maple Leafs and the golden knights gobbled
him up while they happened to be in Toronto he
just shifted locker rooms prior to that Series
against Winnipeg mik mattio had played exactly
one playoff game and on we play 44 tie 1630 to
go in the second overtime oh and a tip Pucket
a shot they score Michael Lano the nights wied
in overtime a double overtime victory for the
golden knights Michael amano's first postseason
goal is an overtime winner 54 Vegas in Winnipeg
the knights take a 2 to1 Series lead he steps up
in the probably biggest goal of his life it's fun
to see those guys get big goals like that and
get a rewarded in those situation certainly
Michael amadio very happy for him maybe the
last guy he would have picked to score the
[Music] [Applause] goal after riding the ship
in the second overtime Vegas would go on to
finish off Winnipeg with two more impressive
victories in games four and five with Chandler
Stevenson Mark Stone and William Carlson
providing the bulk of the scoring and La
Brasa winning four straight in the net also now
you got guys you rely you play a lot of minutes
for you starting to find their game now you
get dangerous and that's what happened those
are stories that happen events that
transpire if you're going to have a
run looming in the second round were the
high-scoring Edmonton Oilers a team team with
a lethal power play led by two of The Game's best
players Leon dryo and Conor McDavid they came off
obviously a series where they're historically
good so I think the confidence was really high
for them we had to be disciplined because I've
never seen anything like it McDavid is dangerous
everywhere but to me he's dangerous when people
start drifting towards him we're thinking of
coming out of the Zone if we haven't created a
turnover low with our first two guys that third
guy really has has to zero in and find him and and
get over top maybe more than pursuing pucks start
low here start low here we go the end of the day
choose our time wisely here to make sure that you
know we got off to a better start MC Dave and dry
they're the two best players in the world playing
with some really good complimentary players on
that power play okay how can we slow them down
neutralize them at times and one of the things we
discussed with the veteran guys is I thought this
would be our most difficult series and I told
the guys that yeah we knew it was going to be
the toughest one that we've had let's make sure
mentally we're ready to match that in our minds
that we can beat this team we're going to have
to do what we need to do to beat this team with
dry cidal and McDavid at the top of their circles
that becomes a little bit of a problem the plan
was we would try to beat them by committee we
would try to neutralize them as best we could
use our depth to beat the rest of their lineup
and then over the course of the series through
Tendencies we would try to find a way to slowly
chip away this is the most dangerous offensive
team in the National Hockey League the first
night dryel did score four goals MC David extra
P score dral from the right Circle and just like
that on script the Oilers power play gives them
a one- nothing lead four minutes into the game
that was the story of the playoffs for us I feel
like we were able to manage momentum swings still
near this SL he score Barb vas ties it going to
work in the crease interior opportunities and the
finish for barbashev cross the lock to the right
a drive and a goal right wi shot from M Mario the
knights Take the Lead two put the knights up two
to one yeah that was a crazy game the shot bent
It Off for bris he could see it coming dry cidal
has the Oilers back within a goal first of all
you think okay he goes off but we won so that
that's a positive for us you know obviously Leon
goes goes off on us for four goals but Barbie was
he was unbelievable that Edmonton series he was
fantastic White Cloud again out High a shot score
K har second of the day we found a way to win
and that was another I think big moment because
that give us some confidence golden knights take
game one 6 four over the Oilers you know we have
a very deep group here and we're going to rely on
our four lines to hang with these guys the Vegas
golden knights set to take on the Edmonton Oilers
game number two after that four goal performance
Leon dry CLE gets the hot streak and you lose
6'4 I guess you're thinking he's not going to
do it again guys execute here it starts with
execution blue tip save rebound score well the
next night it gets two more so what timer score
game two was an eye opener for us McDavid shoots
and scores the Oilers pouring it on job boys
Oilers are three for five on the power clip
and in the playoffs an almost otherworldly 14
of 24 they were clearly better in our building
and 18,000 people in Vegas have been been
absolutely silenced got the lead we chased the
game we're never able to get back into it and
Ed to polishes off Vegas 51 to even this best
of seven Western Conference semifinal at a game
of piece the Oilers put the golden knights away
early after the jolting game two loss the knights
needed to regroup quickly for game three and when
his team needed him the most the smallest of the
original Misfits came up big Maro centering pass
deflected eel at the left side of the Maro
in front and he scores Jonathan Maro finds
the garbage in the crease and he ties the game
Jonathan's offensive production had not been
there in the first round but you could see the
spark that he had when Jonathan maraso gets hot
he stays hot and that's exactly what happened
off of Maro and into the goal Vegas takes a two
to1 lead second goal of the day for Maru it was
a high-scoring series so we needed a guy like me
to get going here you could see Jonathan start
to find his game and the chemistry the Synergy
with barbashev and with eel he scores first on
the road it's a super important game you always
want to keep the lead in the series marchie
was fantastic it was great to see him get on
the board there that's when he started firing
on all cylinders I just wanted to step up and
help my team win a hockey game had a pretty good
first period but on the way to a convincing win
Vegas was dealt a serious [Applause] blow that
one stung right you never want to see a teammate
go down played in the miners never complained
just went about his business came up gave us
unbelievable starts and kind of became that guy
so to see him go down was hard Lauren bris injury
that's a huge moment for the golden knights so
now Aiden Hill steps in played well during the
regular season the confidence was there in Aiden
the question mark was he's missed a lot of time
and they're going into a very very high pressure
and high intensity playoff series with the most
dynamic offensive team in the league they'll
test him early and there's Hill with traffic
in front trapping a shot I've always liked like
big moments I've lik playing against good teams
good players it's more fun to play in those
games I kind of see it as a challenge here's
McDavid and he tests him and Aiden Hill gobbl up
the wrer from McDavid I don't think it matters
who you're playing when you're in the Stanley
Cup playoffs you're going out there to play to
win at one time shot kicked out by Hill winning
that first game and making some big saves and the
team not even blinking we know Aiden can do it
we're moving on here he then becomes a central
figure in the story of the 2223 golden knights
after entering the game midway through the first
period Aiden Hill would face 24 Shots and stop
them all while Jack ik pitched in with a goal and
two assists giving him 10 points through eight
playoff games as Vegas continued its dominance
away from home winning its third straight on
the road to take a two games to one series
[Applause] lead the Oilers enter a pivotal
match up against the Bolton Knights looking
to rebound on home in hopes of tying up this
series two nights later it was the Oilers
who jumped on the golden knights with three
first period goals on their way to a 4 to1 win
scor oers got an early start and they will
tie the second round series through four
games and sure enough it's 2-2 and it's pretty
evenly matched back at home the knights look
to Rebound in the pivotal game five hey let's
enjoy the mall we put ourselves in a position
home game game five let's take advantage of
it right once again however it was Edmonton
that took an early lead to Ryan n Hopkins he
waits now he shoots rebound McDavid scores
that game had some some back and forth
Martinez shot bounc in the Michel scores
it didn't take long but this game is tied
at one a piece h a shoots and they score
well gold Heights been a strong second period team
left to take over once again here down a goal sck
was Mark stick to the [Applause] face well the
Goan nights are looking for a moment this is it
a huge five on three here the left do down to the
goal line St SL score two2 tied 555 to go second
period ston fight five on three goal is huge you
got to take advantage of those opportunities when
you get him and at that key moment of the game in
the series everybody talks about our power play
right not good enough not good enough but uh it
scored clutch goals for us oh a huge moment the
go kns needed to take advantage of and what
a play by the captain that was the first one
the next unit jumped over the boards and they got
one barashev Creeps in off a body they score it's
Riley Smith it's another Power Play strike and
it gives the knights a gain five advantage of
3 to2 Power Play Goals 29 seconds apart and
the Knights are in front for the first time
man haager scores the goal a minute after that
to the point first shot they score Nicholas H
for two nights off and rolling and they've taken
control in the late stages of the second period
in just 89 seconds the knights had exploded
for the three fastest goals in their playoff
history we proved it time and time again
that when we get rolling nobody can keep
up with our team speed we just take over
games and didn't matter when the switch
would flip but near the end of period
two their newly earned 4-2 lead would
be in [Applause] Jeopardy five and a
game is going to be a five in a game
forar we have to kill a major penalty their
power play had done so much damage that
you're thinking wow this might be something
that really test us whether we can overcome
this we knew how important that penalty kill
was going to be playoff hockey is all about
neutralizing strengths and taking advantage of
some weaknesses and sure enough we were able
to push through those tough moments fighting to
recover was dve CLE but his pass is intercepted
and it's cleared all the way down the ice and
the fact that we only gave up one here he comes
Conor mcdavid's in he score Conor McDavid wills
it ho the third power play goal for the Oilers
they're within one Oh I thought you know that
was a win for our group a shot fought off the
rebound Hill say noow momentum builder for us
and now our crowds into it our fans are pretty
knowledgeable they G of gave us a standing
o after we only gave up one and killed off
the majority of the 5 minutes I looked at that
major penalty as something that worked in our
favor and we didn't really allow much the rest
of the way the clock Runs Out night win Vegas
Four Edmonton three the Knight survive and
take a 3 to2 Series lead you can kind of see
how hyped everybody was to celebrate that win
that gave us a ton of momentum going into game
six fellas you're on TV again in our case the
coaches our work is basically done we've done
our prep work now let's just kind of sit
around and wait to be honest with you we
thought we were in an enviable position to
close out the series our guys were ready
here we go he uh had a good start with Riley
had a good goal here and a goal from Riley
Smith and for the first time in this series
The Vegas golden knights strike first take a
deep breath and boy did this building get quiet
in a hurry they came right back with one M he
scor what a response from the Oilers
Captain this game is tied and one a
piece two goals in the first minute and
two D has they score s f two straight for
Edmonton they're up by one early lot
of hockey left here a lot of hockey
that's going to do it for the first
period the Oilers with a one goal lead
regret this Boys Hey coming after that ear
Mission felt like there was a good confidence in
our group come on boys we go Golden Knights Trail
the Oilers two to one in the second period it was
a big turning point in our whole playoff series we
just started dominating a little bit more and
we took over play some good hockey that's all
we're worried about Play Good hockey great play
Jonathan marsho finds the garbage in front pots
the goal ties the game Jonathan maraso continues
his Stellar play of late hey Jack what a play on
the reload he reload hey good defense leads
to good offense all the time keep reloading
here Bluer next Whoever has the puck look for the
onetime by Rolling Martinez SLP shot save up into
the air off the post they score yeah Neymar what
a bullet Marsha so again and the Knights take a
three to2 lead the thing that really propelled
Us in that game was you know marchie's a heart
and soul guy and he's a goal scorer here's a
for Mar and he scores being able to do that I
think the emotion continues to run really high
after that Mar shoots he scores it's a hatrick
for maraso the knights have a 4 to2 lead with a
minute 24 to go in the second period he explodes
for a hatrick we just felt so good about our
game at that point when you're scoring like he
was scoring you know you're feeling it you're
confident it's pretty cool to watch you don't
get a lot of opportunities to take maybe the
best team in the league out of the series we
knew we had to cash in and that opportunity
and I just stepped up at the right time just
another part of the journey where certain guys
stepped up another player who stepped up was the
Aiden Hill after giving up two goals in the
first three minutes Hill went the final 57
plus and gave up none wasn't the start that
Aiden Hill wanted but boy has he settled in
to be the unlikely hero here in game six for the
golden knights for hilly to go up there and make
38 saves McDavid shot Sav by Hill his best of
the night the question all season long was how
would the biggas goal tending hold up everybody
said goal tending was our issue at the start of
the season it sure wasn't right Aiden kept us in
that game we went into the third same thing got
a couple big saves shot oh what a save by Hill
he threw out the blocker and made the save to
keep it 4 to2 we had confidence a Swagger to us
every day we never felt like we were going to be
chasing anything we thought it was all coming to
us it's always fun winning on the road too when
we feel like we can put our foot on the gas or you
know sort of step on their throat and the golden
knights are going to the Western Conference
Final we didn't want it to go to game seven
we never faced an elimination game all playoffs
it was about trying to take out teams when we
can and finishing the job game is over the series
is over Knights advance to the Western Conference
Final and boy fellas Good Luck Good Luck Good
job Leon we're halfway there fellas halfway Mery
great game man I'm not giving it back to couple
huge [Applause] [Music] [Applause] stops yeah
boys uh let's enjoy it tonight and uh watch
that game tomorrow and you're ready for the
next [Applause] one up next for the knights the
the Dallas Stars in a rematch of the 2020 Western
Conference Final the fourth time in six seasons
Vegas has been one of just four teams left in the
playoffs the focus heading into the Dallas series
was we knew how tough of a series Dallas would be
we knew it was going to be a battle but we were
for sure feeling good about ourselves we knew
against them it's always tight games and we're
underway we had to be comfortable to be in tight
games against Dallas the first game we played
really well thought it was one of our better games
and he's snapped It Wide off the back wall goal
William Carlson has tied it at one now it comes to
Carlson and he scores again William Carlson makes
it two to one the lead for the first time tonight
for the homestanding Vegas golden knights Kosar
power to the net it's in the net and it's going to
count bler has put Vegas back on top fourth
line goal for the golden knights and a 3-2
lead Dallas carrying the play desperation time
for the Stars ERS out the extra attacker is off
for hinan rebounds fre and it comes to Ben
and he scores Jamie Ben with 159 to go has
tied it at three game one they scored late in
the game to tie it it's tough going into that
Locker room after you know you could have just
closed up the game and it's not done you got
to go back out there but came up flying played
the right way it's like one chance somebody's
going to be a hero and it might be someone
you don't expect we had a lot of different
Heroes through the playoffs Stevenson with
some speed centers it Stone down low off the
Stick of Howen then he tries to jab it and he did
Brett Howden game winning overtime goal how scirt
some huge goals for us whole playoffs and you
know he was the hero that night against Dallas
sometimes it's the players your surprised by a
game winning goal in a one nothing series lead
BR how good teams find ways to win and
we proved that all year good job thank
[Music]
you so you win a big emotional
game game in game one and then
you go to game two we won the game
push it aside let's get to the next
one come on here be
physical hey the hole come on hands scoring 10
game two probably not our best we had a hard
time getting through Brian s that one locked
down in front hykin in it's a goal head back
back here but get him back boys let's go hang
around the slot there Stevie hang around the
slot eel let's go EO don't be afraid to shoot
the puck move move the puck Maro the Stevenson
CED it rebound goal Mark Stone from right on
in front of the [Applause] net here we go and
Dallas back on the power play come on guys
we got to get going here come on strength of
our game is our Pace don't overthink it here
Robertson all kinds of room up high for Suter
one timer and the rebound goal Robertson
off the original shot by Theon off nice
boys to me the only area we got ourselves in
trouble a little bit there is I think we tried
to make make some plays that weren't there you
know we're going to be successful D you're going
to it's going to hurt in there a little bit we're
going to have to work real hard in that area same
with the other end right so let's make sure we
tilt ice in our favor just as is easily go the
other way so let's sure we're mindful of that
all right let's go win this period man come
on [Applause] here as we head to the third period
Dallas with the two to one leading it there it is
on we're one shot away work back for the puck
work back for the puck we'll be all right Jake
ainger he's a great goalie he made a ton of saves
and he was making it tough on us stopped by oder
didn't have a tongue going offensively down to
the back carry a stop by maraso doesn't have a
shot it's really been a nice job by Dallas
You' never hear this building as quiet as
it is right now it was funny after the last
commercial break there I asked Bruce on the
bench what time he wanted me to come for the
extra attacker right around two Petro looked
over at me know what I mean so it's not half
and half we're all he's like we're scoring
before that happens and they make one mistake
in fast barbashev behind the centers one and
they score Jonathan maraso off a beautiful feed
by I [Music] call what a pass Jackie oh my God
we're able to make a play and Mary once again
right plays hero and that's a huge goal for
us I think that's the biggest goal of my life
that turn the series around two two at the end
of three and we push it to overtime hilly made a
fantastic save to start overtime oh boy Martinez
in trouble with the right come on here a golden
opportunity in the first 30 seconds of overtime
sto across the line has Theodore Theodore
shot rebound goal Vegas wins in overtime
saw the rebound kind of go over to Stevenson
there and just holding my breath with that red
light turned on we scored that goal everybody
the building erupts we all erupt I mean it's
it's just pure excitement the people are on their
feet now they get to celebrate again as Stevenson
makes it a two nothing series lead and all of a
sudden you're up two nothing and you're like God
that went by quick we played well but not great
same with Dallas we just had happen to be the
team that found the the way to score in overtime
another win for Vegas to take a 20 series lead
and they'll head to Dallas with a strangle hold
on the Western Conference Final to nothing now
you're in the driver's seat now you're at 10 wins
I mean you need 16 now you're in double digits so
it's getting [Applause] [Music] closer we leave
for Dallas it's like we're past the halfway point
here so you take some momentum from that and
we certainly did it's their first home game
in the Westy Conference Final anytime you're
up two nothing you're thinking okay if we have
a chance to go up 3 nothing you really get a
strangle hole in the series there's going to
be a little bit of doubt and we can help that
for them right we can help it with a good start
here playing our toes put it behind them and
they D start thinking here we go yeah anytime
you go into roll building you want to have
a good start right you want to pounce on the
best you can and we did that luck is dropped
and we are underway got a hit back here let
him know early CL down a loose B be left the
shot they score Mel Maro Vegas strikes first
hey don't turn down a shot here if you going to
have good starts on the road get the first goal
W across the line right wing to the left wing
a shot SC FR out a power play goal second goal
can kind of quiet the building and put a lot
of pressure on the on the opposing team blug
feeds carry a inside will yes well yes well he
scores backhander inside the right post what a
ball will as the horn signals the end of period
one three goals for the [Music] knights it's fun
getting into those buildings and silencing the
crowd we had an amazing start we just took the
wheel out of them I don't know if we could have
played a better first period and then cuz you
have that lead you're feeling a little confident
and yeah we just carried that momentum throughout
the rest of the game the trango shot [Applause]
[Music] scores job boys Alex petrangelo first
goal of the playoffs 4 nothing Vegas the series
is quickly getting away from Dallas until in our
favorite our team recognized that the rest of the
game keep playing right we keep on playing we've
earned our lead so we got 20 minutes to go let's
go finish the job here let's go let's go let's go
Barbie Aiden gets a shut out so now he's
building his individual confidence golden
knights four star zero the first shut out in
Aiden Hills playoff career to give the knights
a 3oh series lead in the Western Conference
Final one win away from punching their ticket
to the Stanley Cup Final now it's three
nothing and so you're at win number [Music]
11 expecting to wrap up the series in
a sweep Vegas was in for a surprise we
went up 3 nothing we feel like they were
just going to give us the series and and
that was the last thing that was going to
happen what a game it's been game four of
the western Conference Final 2-2 after three
periods first the knights lost game four in
overtime left side shot score pavelski a
onetime Joe Peli sends this series back
to Vegas after a 32 game four win did we get
ahead of ourselves I don't know I just felt
like yes we could win but it wasn't that
quiet confidence we had in those other
games then struggled in game five at home although
they were tied at two heading into the third
before giving up two goals and a surprising 4 to2
loss it was annoying I mean we had two chances to
close out the series and failed those two times
why would we let them come back in that series I
was just disappointed over all everybody was and
so for the first time in the play playoffs the
golden knights had lost consecutive games and had
to head back to Texas for game six regroup move on
get on the plane head to Dallas and get ready to
win one game come on boys opportunity here play
with desperation knock him right out of this game
good time to end it boys time to end it eh game
six in front of a fired up crowd here at American
Airline [Music] Center Puck is dropped and we are
underway from the Western Conference Final right
from the drop of the puck Vegas overran the Stars
jumping out to a quick lead and never looking back
Ste marry that guy Kier gets it in front he shoots
he scores William carrier a backhand goal and for
the third straight game the knights take a one-
nothing lead now low Smith Carle Carley rebound
goal William Carlson a power play goal and it's
two nothing Vegas B pass to him left Circle back
in front colar scores what the golden knights have
taken a three nothing lead gave them no life about
as silent as 18532 can be three nothing early on
every Line's going over the boards playing
the right way our fourth line goes out and
dominates everything every coach tells their team
in the playoffs is what we did that night I just
happened to be the perfect storm of a playoff game
for us played our best game in the playoffs by far
it's Vegas golden night talky four lines chipping
in and get Aiden with a Shad out Aiden Hill was
tremendous his reads were unbelievable his
positioning he was always score on the puck there
was was some silly talk today there was a crack
in Eden Hill absolutely Preposterous you need a
perfect shot to beat him and it didn't happen you
love it and you have a sold out building that's
just dead silent because of what you're doing
with their team I mean it's pretty remarkable
kind of the goalie Carousel we had this year for
him to step up such a great story we're also so
happy for him hey did you play good good job go in
all that was left now for the golden knights was
one question did you guys lift the trophy or not
Florida did what would they do about an old hockey
Superstition I knew that in 18 we we touched it
and we grabbed it all right Bruce I don't think
we're going to touch that one really you don't
care we lost last time we touched it it didn't
work out for us so I was like maybe we shouldn't
touch that one you know like focus on the next
one I was proud of them did what
they had to do and and did it with
a a purpose an exclamation point
so to speak there it's going to
be a big Theory against against for us
so remember that feeling let's go get
it in the back your mind you're
thinking okay these guys have now
seen what their best looks like so now
it's good timing because you need your
best in the final Cheers Cheers
here we go four more fellas four
more the Stanley Cup Final the knights would
face the eighth seed from the East the Florida
Panthers whose miraculous playoff run already
included knocking out the teams with the three
best records in the East for Vegas this would
be a second trip to the Stanley Cup Final and
regardless of the opponent this team knew they had
what it took to win when you get to the final it's
just a different feeling there's a confidence but
I thought we had some Swagger to our group come
on ION say hi C we skate get some looks Fus some
tonight everybody was talking about how well they
were playing and no one was talking about how well
we were playing so that was good for us and it is
a glittering stage for game one of a Stanley Cup
Final that will produce a first time C Champion
the emotions are so high it's a Stanley Cup Final
get off to a bit of a slow [Applause] start one
minute remaining on this B power play Panthers com
in three on two short-handed londell with the pass
Rock attemp Eric stall he scores short-handed goal
the Panthers take a one- nothing lead in game one
it was chaotic but we were able to weed through
the chaos a bit we're able to regain the momentum
again pass away to the right wing [Applause] St
score maruso ties it Go Baby P big sure he puts
some juice into that one again an inside for
br's right side and the crowd like sound the
knights finish the [Applause] first in the first
period Aiden Hill made eight saves but none as
remarkable as the first one in Period two onour
feeding right out in front oh of great stick sa
oh my God oh my goodness Hill out of position
to his left reach back into the creas with his
goal stick or goenda the best save of all time
I saw the pass going over to kachuck there slid
across trying to get my body in position to make
the save just reached out my stick as far as I
could and watch shac hit my stick at that point
it's just pure desperation people forget that
petrangelo hung around the front of the net and
blocked the next chance as well what petrangelo
to J he stops it they always cut it short they
don't see mine they just show insane I was just
just there I thought he had an open that again
that's why you always got to keep playing right
it's a good play by them but was a better play
by Hy it's cool and it'll be a moment I remember
forever it's a wild moment deflates their bench
and juices up ours why you getting me healthy oh
my god oh they're still buzzing here they can't
believe it then Theo scores that incredible goal
and shortly thereafter and just brings so much
energy gets it again he shuffles spins around
keeps the puck along walks to the middle and
[Music] scores Jay theor gives the knights a
2-1 lead 906 to go second period come on that
gets off last minute 12 seconds in the period
marov wins the draw shot and they score Anthony
duclair from the top of the right Circle up a
clean face off win and this game is tied settle
down we're good we're good we had a two to1 lead
wasn't a great goal yet it was a tough one to give
up with 11 seconds to go in the second period it
was such a bad balance actually think it went off
Way's foot but you just go to the room you kind of
laugh at it um it's a bad break take care of the
puck it's not about you know one period this is
about for however long it takes right so this is
a mentality that we're going to just keep playing
that way to break them down but as we've done all
playoffs our guys are good at put things behind
them I'm glad that goal happened at the end of the
second not the start of the third right so because
you get some time to sort of collect yourself get
back at it when you're races and battles that'll
come we go win the game here let's go man we're at
home we're tied all we got to do is win a period
And there's win number 13 come on gold energy
energy everybody let's go let's go that's yours
Whitey that's yours boy Whitey now barbash into
the slot for White Cloud he [Applause] [Music]
scores 32 Vegas 13 minutes to go in the
third sack White [Applause] Cloud as that
game progressed they could feel it it was going
to be really difficult on them to try and keep up
with us because we're just such a Relentless
team Florida Panthers have never won in this
building and we just took over the game back at
it come on go let's get the next one here comes
out High though White Cloud is there white cloud
shoots Walker save CL getes the rebound Stone a
steel he scores K Chuck tried to clear the Zone
Stone sensed it the whole way like a heat sinking
missile there was no high stick on the FL
the knights to the power play as a result
of the failed challenge get the fourth one
and then get the empty Netter to kind of
seal game one e with a steal starts it
out for Smith he shoots he scor [Music]
[Applause] put this one in the books
Vegas 5 Flor two the nights take a
10 series lead in the Stanley Cup Final you
great game Whitey long overdue H have a job
today yes uh great game tonight boys team effort
way to keep our composure let's go get the next
one [Applause] Monday okay there is a belief
in here it's 13 wins so we're going to start
working on 14 for game two the golden knights
were once again prepared for battle first
mentally over big opportunity here he boys
big opportunity is it ever yeah let's go
here E driver's seat and then physically
Vegas leads the series one game t on time
let's go let's go let's go underway in game
two Panthers dump it in Good Start Boys good
start here Florida I think their game plan
was to come in and see if they could push
us around get it to the net man get it to the
net they' had some success against the other
teams yeah it's all right hit to make a play
that's hockey that's not going to work against
us leave it let a waste of energy The More We
Get dragged into the fight in that regard the
better off our team plays and I think it just
fueled us and we matched them hit for hit and
probably had the better part of that physicality
I mean barbashev was an animal out there what a
h what aeny coming uph look out pan looking for
more how to be able to hold your own and end some
and actually be the Punisher they're wasting
more energy triping I stick with it man we got
off to a great start again [Applause] Stevenson
stears it across Ares so he shoots he [Applause]
scores got the power play goal I think
you shoot that you're in the middle of
the ice shoot it get a second one bar with it
again Martinez pu bouncing on he scor let's
go and now'll do it for the period the
knights score two in the first period
Marcelo and Martinez and a two nothing
Edge to the first intermission in game
two we're going into the second with a with
a comfortable lead we're we're feeling good
about the way we're playing get our feet moving
again we all he go go go go go I got you go on
G with w w one off by Veri into the left
corner W walks out in front and scores ni
W Wy scored the third goal on incredible
patient play Wy scores a big goal in the
second it didn't matter who it was the depth
of our team really showed and that depth on
the Vegas bench ran deep even down to JW aen the
team's very observant assistant equipment manager
let's go baby let's go baby St a hit on forsley
without the stick now he picks up the new one from
the bench and joins the play with Stevenson
here stone with that new stick SLS it across
score BR Howen for
nothing blocked that shot knew the stick was
broken but it wasn't in half so you know I kept
going put it in front stot and a rebound put right
underneath H out the back door I broke the stick
kind of on purpose one you're useless without a
stick so you try to lay a hit do something sty
makes a great play pushes his defenseman out of
the Z in my head I thought I got to get to the
bench and get a stick JW the equipment manager he
already knew it was broken saw the boys coming up
the ice with a buck my eyes got pretty big Stevie
made a great play open up the ice you know Howen
makes an incredible goal and make it for nothing
the game's probably over not possible without our
equipment manager and J dubs was on if we could
have got him an assist on the play I think we
would have tried and they chase Sergey vosi
Alex lion will replace him we're into their
backup goalie even when the Panthers tried to be
tougher than the golden knights it didn't work out
as well for Florida as it did for Vegas big hit
on Jack eel what a hit right a Chuck on eel and
Mel is head straight off to the golden knights
pitch and down the tunnel to the locker room
you good Jacko and I lost my wi I couldn't
breathe he bounces back comes right back the
next period Michael to Maro all alone he scores
Maro makes it 51 probably took some wind out of
their sail seeing him respond like that and
make a great play to get us another goal to
extend the lead anything that happened in
game two in the physicality part of it I
thought made us a stronger and better team and and
probably weakened that a little bit mentally 72
the knights smack down the Florida Panthers the
knights have never been this close to a Stanley
Cup Championship it was pretty seral I mean
you're up two nothing going to Florida you're
two wins away from winning the Stanley Cup
it's what you dream of yeah brother good job
good the golden kns have outscored the
Panthers over the first two games 12 to
four they lead the series two games to done
heading into game three Vegas had its sight
set on taking a nearly insurmountable
series lead the tenor of which was
about to change with a devastating
first period hit on Florida's best
player K just took a heavy hit about as heavy
as you can get hit by Keegan kashar Matthew
kachu is making his way into the runway
behind the Florida bench she's now going
in the locker room we're up 2-1 we're trying
to protect our lead they threw everything at
USI heads to the bench with 230 to go we're just
hoping we get that empty net we're hoping we can
seal the game be up 3 nothing for the rest of
the night it looked as if the golden knights
would continue their winning ways until
Matthew kachu came back and came through
deck blad near Point looks across big drive
for H three rebound they scor it's Matthew
KCK on the doorstep and this game is tied
at two with 213 to play in regulation time
game three headed to overtime overtime comes and
they're 6 and0 in overtime Vegas in control with
the puck in that overtime we just weren't
you know on our toes to go take it crit
[Music] [Applause] CR and the Panthers
cut the series deficit in half leaving
the ice that day frustration that we
weren't up 3 nothing 3 nothing and 2
to one is Monumental when you're in that [Music]
moment I just thought that day get away from
the rank mentally I didn't want to push an
agenda that day other than okay let's detach
here a little bit and get back at it toor guys
just give me um a second for me the mindset is
I thought we did a lot of lot of things really
well last night certainly well enough to win give
them credit they made a play and we move on right
we get ready for game four now I still think all
three games we've played as the better team and
that's got to be our mindset going into game four
so I want you know make sure that we're in a good
place it's s to lose and and you should have
that taste in your mouth after a game but now
we're moving on right we're turning the page we're
getting ready for game four and how we're going to
do that today is kind of relax get away from the
rink then back to work tomorrow right good thanks
all right see you tomorrow the message to the
group was let's regroup and just you know put
our best foot forward here for game four ready
to start discipline Focus execution don't give
them a sniff tonight we're the better team guys
we got to play like it hey everybody Welcome
inside FL live arena for tonight's game four 2023
Stanley Cup Final we didn't want the series get
to 22 we couldn't let them tie it up so we had
to go and kind of make a statement there white
red that was important for us to let them know
that hey we mean business today we're not happy
we lost a game the other night so we're here to
play and then that's how we came up back out to
White Cloud Here Comes Stevenson moving it on
rosi [Applause] St 1 minute 39 seconds in let's
go let's go let's go I made a behind the back
pass to White Cloud and we transition and was
a bad change it was actually a broken play
and it was White Cloud that ends up making
the play Stevie that kind of speed no one's
catching him makes a great play to get us
started put them on their heels right away
and got them into a negative mindset very
quickly back
St Chandler Stevenson has his second goal here in
game four oh see Mega sends it back in
barbish collides with Judas far corter
Maro in as well to the middle it's
h a r shot Brock rebound [Applause]
score William Carlson three nothing golden knights
oh boy Carl up three the knights appeared to be in
total control but Florida would continue to fight
eventually cutting the lead to a single goal front
right trickle shot and they score I can't sit down
I can't sit down and then as the clock wound down
with Vegas short-handed and frantically holding on
Valiant K Chuck nearly tied the game oh it's all
over the Golden KN wi it 3 to2 it was chaotic
and credit to our penalty kill I mean six
on fours are so tough we can't say enough
about those guys that were on the ice it's
desperation at its finest and for the Golden
Knights by virtue of picking up this Victory
they've got a chance to close out the series
and the season game five Tuesday night the
Stanley Cup will be in the building they have
never been this close they are one game away
uh great win boys um I mean not much needs
to be said we know uh what next game means
so let's get it best be of the year one more
the hardest one to get do it in front of the
fans Bruce Cassidy challenged his team and and
then Bruce's willingness to keep talking about
the moment and say I'm not afraid to talk about
it we win these games we win the Stanley Cup our
guys know it we're acutely aware of it we're not
going to run and hide from it there's going to be
a lot of people in the rear when you're one game
away and if it means discussing certain things
with family members about you know the Stanley
Cup or you know whatever you want to talk about
then I think that's okay I mean that's what
we're planned for I don't think there's any
tabos with that they understand what's at stake
don't think about you know how hard it's been to
get here and you know what's required to finish
the job game five Stanley Cup Final and for the
golden knights the Stanley Cup is in the
building a win will clinch the series for
the golden knights a celebration for the city
of Las Vegas and their first ever Standley Cup
Championship I was just thinking of the game
I go through ideas in your head and I thought
you know what it' be a nice gesture towards
the original golden knights players to start
them I think it'll be a nice tip of the cap to
them and give the re room a little bit of juice
so to speak there's six guys that have been here
since day one that built the foundation for this
team so you guys can get us going here tonight
get a start in the right direction Carly Smitty
Marsh theoa naber hli and nuts here let's go
in the first everyone knows what the Misfits
mean to the community really brought the community
together and allowed people to fall in love with
this team they're just going to get us started
on the right foot and there's no way they're
beating us tonight one more win to clinch the
cup Sony started off again he was just pick up
the puck like create turnovers for them and just
go the other way Panthers carried back in an Eric
drop pass gathered ahead still on one stone with
Stevenson Stone stop shoots he [Applause] scores
the first short-handed goal for the knights this
postseason the captain Mark Stone gives Vegas a
one- nothing lead I was fortunate that they
didn't connect on a pass takes it all the way
down the left wall I realized that I was pretty
much standing in the crease just want to make a
play to get that incredible crowd going absolutely
huge turning point and of all guys you want to get
that first goal it's Mark Stone because of the
inspirational guy is and how much energy you
get off him scoring and great individual play
so good for the team and from there here we
go we're not looking back this is going to be our
night Mel right side pulls to the middle couldn't
get a shot away now he does it's loose at the
goal line another try they [Applause] score two
nothing Vegas that will do it for a p let's have
a big second here set ourselves up for the third
eh ahead they look the catch the
Panthers on a change Mel martinz star
we had them hemed in their zone
for about 3 minutes there score
a goal then we do it again and score a
goal they're wearing down boysson ACR
SMI for bu and it was 4-1 and at that point it
felt like it was Game Over Stevenson down the
right side dropping it back for how pass yeah
and second of [Music] the there was a 5 six
7 Minute period in the second period that I have
never seen such domination and the golden knights
have taken a 61 [Applause] [Music] lead it was
fun to sit on the bench when I wasn't out there
and watch we had such a good second period
like this is going to happen it's going to
happen we're going to get it Doney who better
to get it done the man the knights call Skip
finish this looking crossy Stone intercept this
time he sends it down it'll walk B and go into
the the in the prer marks down
the captain makes it 83 golden
knights you just want to get over there with your
teammates that was the first time where
I realized that we're going to win the
Stanley [Music] [Applause] Cup missfit
the Champions the Vegas Golden Knights
win the Stanley Cup in [Music] [Applause] [Music]
hey 6 Years baby we're [Applause] how
good is that I got tears in my eyes cuz
I know what just happened now you're on the ice
looking for your family you want to touch every
player thanking them for their commitment don't
go far for what with this the con Smite Trophy
goes to the most valuable player in the playoffs
five for first for goals and an original golden
night thank you I did it for you did
it for me man you did it for me it's
the best thing I've ever seen simply
awesome thank you in a second take it
away what's the trophy order going to be when
are they bringing the thing out I want to see
it I want to grab it not only is Vegas a
hockey town it's a championship Town Mark
Stone our tradition for this 130y old trophy
is to present it to the [Applause] captain
you had a great night too great season
congratulations pick it up let's take some
pictures the
hor the best moment of my hockey career be
able to pick that thing up I'll never forget
that tradition plays a big part in any Stanley
Cup postgame celebration take the passing of the
cup which usually goes from the captain to the
most worthy teammate and while Stone does follow
suit it really goes to a group of players in no
specific order the golden misfets the remaining
Six Original golden knights who helped build
the foundation that ultimately led to this
Championship fact that we were able to do that
with that group of guys it's something I'll uh
definitely never forget it brings everybody
together that was a very very special moment
there's no feeling like like it something you want
to do your whole life it was pretty incredible
it's a childhood dream come true picking up that
trophy lifting it over your head and being able
to kiss it you know what it was truly special
the best part is when you get handed the trophy
yes yes yes yes and you're putting it over
your head as you can tell very emotional yeah
we had the one last Puck that we wanted to
get up one last presentation for this
season if anybody's going to retire it
cap I love being in Vegas golden night love my
teammates we grinded hard for this boys uh we got
the greatest group of guys we pulled it off and
now we're the best te I say oh my god oh my god
what have I done get that puck up the 16th Puck
had just meant the world to me and my [Music]
teammates of course no Stanley Cup celebration
is complete without a parade for the Vegas Golden
Nights there was only one place for that to happen
we got a big crew here we want a up it's a
pretty cool shot to see all the cops driving
we are headed to celebrate with our great fans of
the city of Las Vegas and the unbelievable parade
that they got planing for us I'm uh Beyond excited
for this man it's going to be uh once a lifetime
experience we knew that this city was going to
show up and show out making that turn was was
the best turn I've ever been a part of this is
a crazy guy that brought us all here and here we
are that was a pretty crazy moment who would ever
thought there would be a Stanley Cup Parade down
the Los Vegas [Music] [Applause] strip you go
down there's so many peoples you see like all
the [Applause] guys it was like a movie they love
us they love us the best part about playing here
are the fans right you enjoy the moment with
them because part of the reason why we're here
the part of the reason that we can do and what
we do and play the game we love we have so many
golden knights fans we have so many people that
support the team to be able to go down there
share some high fives spray some champagne into
the crowd was a special special [Music] event
seen the support out there both sides of the
street just flooded with people go it's awesome
just feeling that support feeling the energy
and how much they love us and we love them
that parade was something I'll never [Applause]
forget Las Vegas this is your stanle [Applause]
P that was pretty crazy when we went out on
stage I never seen that many people in front
of me before in my life I was expecting there to
be a lot of people but my God couldn't believe
my eyes when we went on that stage how loud it
[Applause] was how happy everybody was to see
us come up on stage with the Stanley Cup it
was incredible being able to be on that stage
with our teammates it was a special site it's a
privilege and an honor to coach the Vegas golden
nights and I'm just just glad they put their
faith in me to get the job done so tonight this
parade is for the fans of the Vegas golden kns
it's for you so enjoy it everybody the ultimate
reward for me especially the way the whole last
year went down a lot happened in that year very
rewarding I've played for a long time but I've
never had this much fun coming to work every
day it's all I got for you it's life changing
for all of us we all got to live a childhood
goal childhood dream and we got to do it with our
best friends something none of us will ever forget
and the moment that we'll want to live over and
over again forever was the most special time in
my life I mean it's sorry just a really special
group of guys special team thank you I did it
for you did it for me man you did it for me it's
the best thing I've ever seen so proud to be part
of it [Applause] the going into the playoffs
we obviously thought we had a team that could
compete and win the Stanley Cup but you never know
we still kept gaining confidence no matter what
happened here I am sitting talking to you guys
as the 2023 Stanley Cup champion Vegas golden
kns